The Greeks had a punishment for the clever eternity pushing a boulder uphill, only to watch it roll back down.
Sisyphus, pointless, exhausting, and yet, somehow, he was the one who got the story.
Now we have our own version.
It's called the Infinite Scroll.
No beginning, no end, just the slow, creeping realization that you've been here for hours and the screen keeps going and the boulder never stops.
The labor movements of the early 1900s would have loved this.
They saw the assembly line, the same endless motion, the same hollow satisfaction of a job well done, only to have it all undone the next day.
But at least the factory whistle blew.
At least the shift ended.
At least there was a clock to punch, a paycheck to collect, a moment to step outside and remember you are still alive.
The Infinite Scroll does none of that.
It dissolves time itself.
Human beings need markers.
A start.
A finish.
A stop.
But the Infinite Scroll?
It has no stop.
It has only next, and next, and next, so you don't notice the hours slipping away.
You don't feel the weight of the boulder in your hands.
You just keep scrolling.
And here's the thing you tell yourself.
It's just one more.
One more post.
One more article.
One more video.
But the screen knows better.
It's designed to lie.
Because there is always another.
Always another.
And so, you never stop.
Some people call it meditation.
They watch the colors blur.
The shapes shift.
The feed refresh.
Their thumbs move like prayer beads.
Their eyes glaze over.
They've mastered sedentary mastery.
The art of doing nothing while pretending to be productive.
The thumb cramp.
A badge of honor.
The dry eyes.
Proof you've earned your place in the digital catacombs.
And then there's the real trick-the-sump cost of attention.
You've already spent an hour.
Might as well spend two.
Might as well spend three.
Because what's another hour when you're already in?
You're gambling now.
Not with money.
With your own focus.
And the house always wins.
The goal?
To turn you into a ghost.
Not a spirit.
Not a memory.
A ghost of the interface.
Sitting in a room.
Staring at a three-inch window.
While the world outside fades into static.
You've spent a lifetime looking.
But you've never really seen anything.
And the screen?
It's just waiting.
Always waiting.
For the next click.
Some people optimize it.
They call it doom-scrolling.
They feed the outrage.
They chase the next outrage.
They turn the infinite scroll into a perpetual motion machine of despair.
A book has a last page.
A screen has only a next page.
And the next page is always the same.
Choose wisely.